as folklorists we take tradition and
Superstition seriously it's fun to talk
about how to protect yourself from
vampires or how to kill a vampire by
staking it through the heart and we're
definitely going to do that in this
episode
but we're also going to talk about the
larger context for these practices and
how they developed in the first place
in Dracula when Van Helsing rallies the
band of vampire Hunters together he
tells them all that all we have to go
upon are traditions and superstitions
these do not at the first appear much
when the matter is one of life and death
may have more than either life or death
yet must we be satisfied in the first
place because we have to be
no other means is at our control and
secondly because after all these things
tradition and Superstition are
everything
even in the face of scientific
innovation Van Helsing asks his friends
to treat Superstition and folk belief as
a vault of knowledge as a parallel way
of seeing the world that he hopes will
allow them to defeat Dracula
folk beliefs are unofficial beliefs that
develop and operate outside powerful
social structures
as scholar David Hufford points out most
academic theories have assumed that folk
belief is false or at least unfounded
non-rational and non-empirical
but the thing is these beliefs can tell
us a lot about how people experience and
make sense of the world beliefs don't
just appear out of thin air out of
context they appear because of a reason
as Hufford adds much folk belief is
reasonable that it is rationally
developed from experience that is to say
the reasoning involved in many such
beliefs utilizes methods of inference
based on observations which are commonly
accepted as valid
hufford's groundbreaking Theory argues
that many Supernatural beliefs are
rooted in reasonable logical attempts to
try and make sense of real bodily or
cultural experiences now Hufford is not
arguing that these beliefs are
necessarily a hundred percent true and
neither are we and neither are we but
rather that they're often rooted in
observations and inference rather than
neurotic defenses or overwhelming biases
or wild Flights of Fancy
if we apply hufford's Theory to vampires
then we can see how folk beliefs about
them are not wholly irrational nor are
they ridiculous in their context with
that in mind we're going to take a close
look at some of the superstitions and
strategies invented over the years with
the hope of protecting oneself from
vampires and also perhaps containing and
killing vampires in order to reveal what
Believers may have been thinking and
experiencing as we do this as we go
through all of these strategies it's
important to keep in mind that Bram
Stoker's construction of vampire lore
for the novel Dracula itself is in the
words of leading Dracula scholar
Elizabeth Miller more haphazard than
scholarly now she doesn't mean this as
an insult after all stoker was not
writing a historical Treatise or a
practical manual detailing how to kill a
vampire that's not what he was doing he
was writing a work of fiction he was
writing a novel but stoker Drew on
whatever Supernatural lore or literature
he could find clients and when he
couldn't find it he'd just make it up he
pulled from authors we've discussed like
John polidori Sheridan the fanu and
others he pulled bits and pieces from
Vampire folklore people things from
werewolf folklore a lot of things a lot
of things surprising number of things
all of these different sources are fair
game for talking about vampires today
though because so much of what stoker
put together all of these bits and
pieces that he combined in order to
create his vampire have solidified into
the version of the vampire that we now
know and that we expect this means that
in Dracula and in most vampire
literature film and other more
contemporary media we're not seeing pure
replications of actual folk beliefs held
by real people that's not what we're
saying instead we're seeing a
kaleidoscope made up of historical facts
folk beliefs transported across culture
and language and literary invention
it's often impossible to pick these
elements apart cleanly but that doesn't
mean this Avenue is fruitless instead it
means that we often learn more about the
time in which a vampire story is told or
written than the earlier eras that they
often describe
let's begin by looking at one of the
classic defenses against vampires garlic
the scent is meant to repel vampires and
keep them away from your person and even
your home
in Dracula Van Helsing drapes a Garland
of garlic around Lucy's neck and fills
her room with garlic blooms which by the
way are purple and look a little bit
like thistles they're pretty they're
yeah they're pretty
the Superstition does predate Stoker's
Dracula garlic as a vampire repellent is
mentioned in one of Dracula's confirmed
sources Emily Gerard's 1885 article
about Transylvanian superstitions
interestingly In some cultures it's the
existence of a strong smell generally
not the actual substance of garlic in
particular that's the problem in Old
Yugoslavia the area now known as Serbia
and Montenegro for example garlic was
one of the things that could be used but
cow dung and anything else especially
pungent were also very effective across
cultures vampires collectively seems to
just hate strong smells as someone with
an overly sensitive nose I'm actually
pretty sympathetic
but there's more to Garlic's efficacy
than its pungency garlic has a history
of being used to ward off evil spirits
generally in folklore its protective
effects aren't specific to just vampires
exactly however culturally we definitely
associate garlic strongly with vampires
right at least nowadays the protective
properties of garlic against vampires
are so well known and expected that it's
frequently depicted as a kind of punch
line in contemporary vampire media
vampires and books are on TV joke about
how much they love garlic bread or
pretend to faint when garlic is
brandished at them it's it works as a
something funny but even when it is a
joke the joke works because of the
strength of the convention we all know
that vampires are supposed to hate
garlic which is what makes the joke work
that said early reviews of Stoker's
Dracula often commented that the
vampiric fear of garlic was funny for
the opposite reason it wasn't yet a
cliche so just some late victorians
powerful blood-sucking monsters fearing
a seasoning broke their suspension of
disbelief however in folklore globally
plants and herbs have all kinds of
powers and these beliefs are often
rooted in observation and experience
very specific Cultural Literacy
determined whether this plant lure is
understood as a cliche a joke or just
good common sense
perhaps the only vampire repellent as
well known as garlic is the cross this
might take the form of wearing a cross
on a necklace or a ring or of carrying a
cross to use as a weapon of intimidation
this is perhaps most famously depicted
in the 1931 Dracula film when Van
Helsing iconically brandishes across at
Bella Lugosi
well the idea of brandishing across as a
weapon is largely a literary invention
all these uses of crosses are part of a
much larger pattern of invoking
spiritual objects and symbols to ward
off evil spirits because American and
European culture is dominantly Christian
there's often an assumption that
Christian symbols are the necessary
tools for the job especially because the
Supernatural is often presented as
anti-christian and therefore of the
devil this chain of logic is why so many
creatures from folklore have aversions
to anything associated with Christianity
this of course covers vampires but it
also extends to fairies werewolves and
all kinds of other supernatural
creatures
in other parts of the world and even
occasionally in American and British
vampire stories sacred symbols from
other faiths are deployed instead like
I've seen a star of David used a couple
times for example
but this strong association between the
devil or at least evil and vampires
means that often crosses or swords
deliberately shaped like crosses
rosaries holy water sometimes even lambs
and Crossroads are all things that can
commonly be used against vampires
this association between religion and
protection also helps us make sense of
why funeral rights could take on so much
weight when fears of vampires were
strong
historian Paul Barber describes
widespread European folk beliefs
intersecting with burial practices in
order to prevent vampirism
for example the lack of a proper burial
might result in an otherwise innocent
body Rising again as a vampire by
practicing proper funeral rights it was
believed you could prevent this from
happening this leads us up to the idea
of containment that's with the right
tools you could prevent vampires from
rising from their coffins at all
certain kinds of deaths were sometimes
thought to increase the likelihood of
vampirism in Christian contexts this
might mean people who committed suicide
were non-Christian hadn't been baptized
or hadn't been given a proper burial
because these people were considered
especially susceptible to vampirism
extra precautions were sometimes taken
yeah and some common methods to prevent
new vampires from rising might include
placing objects in the grave things like
coins or garlic or candles or seeds to
count we see evidence for this practice
in Germany but also globally in places
like Canada and Macedonia
the idea was that the vampire would
become too preoccupied with counting
these objects to rise from their coffin
and do any real harm
folklorists have literally described
this as harnessing the vampire's
compulsions
it's a fascinating humanization of the
vampire
and if a vampire is a bit human then
perhaps it can be trapped and outsmarted
by humans
likewise it was thought that if you
threw a bunch of little objects into a
vampire's path think like a handful of
rice the vampire would have to stop and
count them all sometimes only at the
pace of one a year could this be how we
got the count like from Sesame Street I
mean the folklore definitely mirrors the
characterization
so putting knots in a coffin with a
suspected vampire's body was another
good distraction method commonly used in
Northern Germany in particular
apparently vampires just can't resist a
really good knot they'll stay in their
coffins picking at it forever which was
said to prevent them from rising as well
if you suspected someone had a chance of
turning into a vampire after death this
was one way you could at least prevent
them from coming out of their grave
so a modern equivalent of this might be
putting like a bunch of crossword
puzzles or like the Wordle archive into
a vampire's grave essentially yeah
basically so this belief and the
distractibility of vampires and their
irresistible compulsions not only for
bloodlust but for counting and puzzle
solving humanizes them they might still
be monsters but they're imperfect
monsters with their own foibles so
perhaps they can be beaten by imperfect
humans seems logical no additionally
people sometimes put sharp objects into
Graves to prevent vampires from rising
and there are even some places like
Poland where they say that all you have
to do is bury a suspected vampire just
like face down sometimes with the
additional precaution of stones over
their heads and because this will stop
them from standing up
other methods of preventing walking
included tying the feet of the corpse
together in Romania and wrapping the
corpse in a carpet in Bulgaria
many cultures also suggest taking newly
dead corpses out of the family home in
unconventional ways like through a
window or even a hole made in the side
of the house once the body was out it
would then be taken to the burial ground
very circuitously so that if the body
Rose as a vampire later it would be
confused and not know where they were or
how to get back to their former home
while this wouldn't prevent the corpse
from rising as a vampire at least it
wouldn't be able to harm its Still Human
family another strategy of containment
is planting particular vegetation over
the graves roses with their Thorns were
a well-known containment strategy that
was used in Dracula but any plants with
thorns that forced a vampires to like
basically rise up straight into built-in
barbed wire any of that would work this
also seems to connect back to the
practice of putting sharp objects into
coffins in Romania there is even
evidence of an automatic vampire
piercing device as Barber puts in
essentially the coffin lid would be shut
the body would be buried and then
several sharp Stakes would be driven
into the grave so that if the body seeks
to rise up out of the coffin it will
immediately be punctured by one of these
stakes and killed
pre-staking a corpse was also very
common but more unstaking in a moment of
course stories about vampires are not
limited to protection and containment
often the most satisfying stories about
vampires involve that vampire being
slain
if the vampire is destroyed it's no
longer a threat and the story is
affirming and Victorious and not just
cautionary or frightening stories about
slaying vampires often involve trying to
find the monsters while they're most
vulnerable while they're sleeping
vampires are usually nocturnal so they
sleep during the day often in coffins
containing their native soil
spotting a coffin in a place it
shouldn't be or finding evidence of a
recently Disturbed grave is often a big
giveaway of vampiric presence tampering
with a vampire's native soil can be an
effective strategy because it weakens
their power by weakening their
connection to their Homeland at least
according to Dracula to the best of our
knowledge this is Stoker's own
contribution to vampire lure but it has
been used to great effect since then too
yes so for example there's a hilarious
episode in season three of the TV show
what we do in the shadows where the
vampires lose their coffin Earth during
this trip to Atlantic City because
housekeeping comes into their room and
throws it all away it's literally a pile
of dirt yeah so housekeeping's like well
I mean we're cleaning up their hotel
room and the vampires come back and
they're like oh oh so this means that
the vampires are unable to sleep leading
to just escalating delirium and finally
in desperation they said they're
familiar as a human helper to all of
their homelands to collect new samples
of native soil for them so that they can
you know sleep and function
in Dracula after the destruction of the
vampire's coffins and Homeland Earth the
primary way for tracking the count is
actually through his psychic connection
to mina this is an especially troubling
tool because while it exploits Dracula's
vulnerability it also exploits Mina's
this connection illicit sympathy sways
emotions and can even be an Avenue of
transformative power the fact that the
vampire Hunters basically use Mina like
a dowsing Rod to find Dracula reinforces
her connection to the supernatural which
is extremely dangerous because it
further erodes the boundary between the
human and the vampiric it's ultimately
effective but the cost is that in order
to destroy the monster Mina has to
invite the Monstrous into her own mind
so once the monster has been found how
you kill it
sometimes the method is surprisingly
mundane or at least not attuned to the
supernatural Stoker's Count Dracula
uslane by having his throat sheared
through and being stabbed in the heart
which is you know gruesome but also a
perfectly effective way of killing a
human pretty sure that would kill
anybody pretty sure but because
Supernatural strength and healing
properties are often tied up with
conceptions of vampirism many methods of
killing them have to be very specific in
order to be effective the most popular
and widespread method for killing
vampires is staking them through the
heart most famous vampire Hunters like
Buffy from Buffy the Vampire Slayer the
TV show use them
so be fair this would kill a normal
human too yeah you know if you ram a
giant piece of wood through someone's
heart you know they're not going to walk
away from you not necessarily but
there's a magical quality to staking as
well in some stories what the stakes are
made of their composition makes all the
difference in the Baltic area for
example tradition states that the
appropriate wood to make a steak is Ash
in Serbia it's Hawthorne recall that
while Stoker's Dracula is killed with
knives other vampires within the novel
like Lucy are staked this method of
killing vampires is definitely mentioned
in Emily Gerrard's article about
Transylvanian superstitions and it's
also present in other vampire literature
that predated Dracula like Farney the
vampire and carmilla stoker was
definitely familiar with the idea that
staking vampires is an effective way to
kill them this Trope continues till the
modern day we've mentioned Buffy already
but it remains one of the most common
ways to kill vampires across all kinds
of media
in the 2013 film Only Lovers Left Alive
which we adore Beyond Reason exactly
staking is reimagined when the
protagonist Adam a vampire who is
suffering from depression considers
committing suicide using a gun loaded
with a wooden bullet he asks that the
bullet bee made from the hardest and
most dense wood and suggests things like
iron wood snake wood or African
Blackwood
while a regular bullet won't kill him it
seems that he could essentially stake
himself with a particularly hard heart
piercing wooden bullet in this way
staking is updated and made more
frightening in context by involving a
more modern weapon that is implicated in
the vast majority of suicides among men
in the U.S another traditional way to
kill vampires is decapitation this
method appears in the folklore of German
and Western Slavic people this is one of
the things that happens to Dracula at
least as we interpret it his throat is
cut and he's also knifed in his heart
stoker writing as Mina in her journal
describes it this way
on the instant came the sweep and Flash
of Jonathan's great knife I shrieked as
I saw it sheer through the throat whilst
at the same moment Mr Morris's Bowie
knife plunged into the heart it was like
a miracle but before our very eyes and
almost in the drawing of a breath the
whole body crumbled into dust and passed
from our sight
Shear through the throat definitely
seems to imply a decapitation
Spades were actually often the
particular weapon of choice for this
though particularly Spades owned by
religious people like Sextons the people
who would look after churches and
churchyards
that seems like a particularly brutal
way to decapitate someone but does
sometimes because of the vampire's
ability to heal themself grave dirt
would be placed between the severed head
and the rest of the body to ensure that
they wouldn't reattach letting the
vampire come back to life
people would also sometimes place the
decapitated head at the feet of the
vampire so he couldn't reach it and
therefore wouldn't be able to heal
if you slice the head off but you know
don't do something to prevent it from
reconnecting to the body there is this
fear that the head and the body could
maybe reattach and come back together
this brings us to our first inherently
magical mode of vampire destruction
which is of course sunlight aversion to
sunlight has become one of the most
famous and recognizable vampire tropes
interestingly Dracula himself isn't
actually harmed by this side of the book
again he's killed with knives
it's also worth noting that even though
Dracula isn't harmed by sunlight he is
heavily impacted by the cycle of day and
night there are times notably a Dusk and
Dawn when Dracula is able to become more
active or have more influence daylight
is still significant in Stoker's Dracula
even if it isn't deadly we actually have
a theory about this we think that
because stoker was reading a lot about
werewolves and werewolf folklore when he
was writing Dracula that there might
have been some slippage between the
categories of vampire and werewolf this
was pretty common pre-20th Century as
we've mentioned before werewolves are
notoriously vulnerable to the moon and
to patterns of day and night so it makes
sense if stoker was reading a lot of
wearable folklore that the patterns of
day and night took on significance in
the novel that he was writing
if Dracula isn't killed by sunlight so
why do we now almost always assume that
sunlight kills vampires there are a few
exceptions of course like Twilight
Springs to mind where the sun doesn't
destroy vampires it only makes them
Sparkle which is honestly kind of an
amazing Twist on this whole sunlight
thing yeah I mean having vampires
Sparkle in the sun really is kind of a
clever adaptation of conventional
vampire tropes it's a Twist on one of
the most expected characteristics of
vampires and they still have a
vulnerability to sunlight because they
can't go out into it without revealing
their Supernatural status without
getting their covers blown it's just
glittering instead of death
and is making vampires glitter and
sunlight really that much Stranger than
having them be terribly adverse to
garlic I don't really think so yeah
vampires don't die when exposed to
sunlight in any pre-dracula literature
that we know of they are staked or
they're decapitated generally on
occasion they even throw themselves into
volcanoes did that too but that said
burning generally is pretty much
universally understood as one of the
chief ways to kill a vampire for good
usually via cremating the corpse to the
best of our knowledge sunlight really
became the thing that kills vampires in
the 1922 German film Nosferatu in which
the vampire perishes after losing
himself in bloodlust and totally losing
track of time this seems to be the point
where the fatality of sunlight really
captured the Public's imagination
it's possible that this is because it
was the first time that most people were
seeing a vampire on screen this death
has a dramatic visual impact after
nosferatsu it quickly became a
convention that vampires die in sunlight
just as it's expected that they drink
blood
the methods of protection from vampires
and destruction of vampires that we've
discussed in this episode are not all
directly pulled from folklore nor are
all the methods outlined by Van Helsing
himself in the novel Dracula but they're
all now part of the lore around vampires
the vulnerabilities we expect the rules
by which we know how to tell or
deconstruct a vampire story
some of these conventions may seem
strange even kind of silly to you but
for the people that believed them the
ideas that did come from folk belief
anyway these strategies were very real
even rational in a way
learning about these folk beliefs
teaches us what people at different
times over the course of history were
afraid of and what they did to prevent
their fears from coming true
they're afraid that Vampires will rise
up and walk the earth again so they
literally stake them down into the Earth
they're afraid of vampires being agents
of hell so they use crosses against them
cutting off a vampire's head means that
it literally cannot bite you
all of these beliefs are reasonable
based on the knowledge available at the
time and that's part of why belief is so
powerful
[Music]
thank you